Leipzig – eine Großstadt, die
wächst und sich ständig verändert,
wie viele Städte weltweit.
Auch hier gibt es die
unsichtbare Gefahr: Feinstaub.
In der Lützner Straße gibt es
besonders viel Feinstaub.
Eine enge Straße mit sehr viel Verkehr,
die vielen Autos sind das größte Problem.
Kein guter Ort zum Wohnen,
sagt Ulrich Franck,
Physiker und Gesundheitsforscher,
der sich seit Jahren mit
Feinstaub beschäftigt.
Zu den Hauptverkehrszeiten ist
die Straße richtig zu
und entsprechend viel emittieren
auch die Fahrzeuge.
Das ist einmal der Staub,
der aufgewirbelt wird
und das ist zusätzlich auch vielleicht
Reifen-, Bremsen-Abtrieb [Abrieb]
und das ist auch noch das,
was aus dem Auspuff kommt.
Besonders gefährlich sind
ausgerechnet die Partikel,
für die bisher keine Grenzwerte
festgelegt worden sind
und die besonders klein sind – ultrafein.
Die Filterscheibe links ist neu.
Die andere aus der Messstation zeigt,
was sich allein an kleinen Partikeln
an nur einem Tag ansammelt.
Sieht nicht gut aus – und hat Folgen.
Ein Jahr lang haben die Forscher
sämtliche Rettungseinsätze
in Leipzig ausgewertet und festgestellt:
Ist die Menge ultrafeiner
Feinstaubpartikel besonders hoch,
müssen mehr Menschen
schnell ins Krankenhaus.
An vielen Orten weltweit sind
die Feinstaubwerte noch höher als hier.
Also wenn wir jetzt in and[e]re Länder
schauen, zum Beispiel nach Indien,
China oder in verschiedene
Entwicklungsländer:
Wir haben dort gewaltig hohe
Erkrankungsraten durch diese schlechte Luft,
also haben ein extrem
erhöhtes Sterbe-Risiko
und Risiko für
verschiedene Erkrankungen.
Das geht hin von Kurzzeiteffekten,
also letztlich Atemwegserkrankung,
Herz-Kreislauf-Erkrankung,
aber auch Langzeiteffekte.
Das sind zum Beispiel
Krebserkrankungen.
Die Forscher haben sich auch mit
Feinstaub in Innenräumen beschäftigt.
Sie wollten wissen, ob Kinder durch mehr
Feinstaub ein höheres Risiko haben,
an Bronchitis zu erkranken.
Das Risiko ist tatsächlich erhöht
– wenn zum Beispiel in
der Wohnung geraucht wird
oder außerhalb viel Verkehr ist,
denn beides lässt die Konzentration
der ultrafeinen Partikel ansteigen.
Die Wissenschaftler haben
auch untersucht, wo in der Stadt
die Feinstaubbelastung hoch
und wo sie gering ist.
Wenn ich mir zum Beispiel diesen
wunderschönen breiten Grünzug
hier in Leipzig anschaue, dann ist das
nicht nur ‘ne Quelle von Sauerstoff,
sondern [er] ist auch ein
großer Frischluftkorridor,
über den Schadstoffe abtransportiert und
Frischluft herantransportiert werden können.
Auch eine offene Bebauung senkt
die Feinstaubbelastung
– wegen besserer Durchlüftung
und weniger Verkehr.
Interessant für Stadtplaner weltweit.
Man kann mit einfachen Mitteln, auch
gerade in schnell wachsenden Metropolen
in der Dritten Welt, sagen,
ich sollte so oder so bauen,
dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass ich
hohe Belastungen habe, deutlich reduziert.
Umweltzonen verhindern, dass Fahrzeuge,
die besonders viel ultrafeine Partikel
freisetzen, in die Innenstädte kommen.
Insofern helfen sie gegen Feinstaub,
sagt Ulrich Franck.
Aber weltweit muss in den Städten
noch sehr viel mehr passieren.
In manchen Städten hilft es sicher,
den öffentlichen Personennahverkehr
zu verbessern,
in ander[e]n Städten hilft es,
die Bebauung so anzupassen,
dass ich ‘ne bessere Durchlüftung (haben)
habe, in anderen wiederum hilft es,
Industrie sauberer zu machen.
Weniger Feinstaub in Städten
wäre also möglich.
Ulrich Franck hat einen Weg gefunden
in die Stadt der Zukunft,
in der man gefahrlos atmen kann.